how's going brothers my fear and welcome
to welcome to my kitchen today we're
gonna do cooking with pills why I don't
know if we're gonna start with one
direction cupcake mix you may be
thinking that's pretty dumb and stupid
why would you do that well I also have
this ghost pepper
ghost chili pepper so I figured I put
one in one of them but I won't know
which one
let's cook these bad boys first we have
to heat the oven this is the microwave
180 all right let's be honest I look
better than any of these it's [ __ ]
unfair why do they have a cupcake okay
where's my beauty pipe cupcakes it's
[ __ ] Zain looks like he's a meth it
does not look like I'm at all butter
we are healing the butter right now look
it's almost like I'm touching it
but I'm not don't worry it's not real
what's he doing again
oh yeah the cupcakes we add the butter
all right let's add the cupcake mix
cupcake
all right it's very hot
what was I doing it's kind of hard to
deal with this will you watch you
alright so don't judge felt terrible
making pancakes bacon make them pancakes
oh why does it smell this bad have I
failed already smell it smell it oh that
is a nasty is this butter old that
expired yesterday hey what are you gonna
double Patek I was doing something we
haven't added the eggs do we even have
eggs hey calm down
how to basic you jelly see if I can one
hand this [ __ ] now for a little taste
open your mouth I said open your mouth
you dirty [ __ ] I'm kidding all right it
looks like ass but it doesn't taste like
ass it's time to put the chili in one of
the boxes all right
I'll put it in this one I look pretty
good now I would say time to put those
[ __ ] in the oven I'm scared of ovens
when I was a kid I got burned I'm scared
I I do
Hey when in doubt spoon it
yeah the magic one okay okay okay ah may
have exaggerated a little bit it didn't
hurt that much
we spent them now we wait the Chili's
giving a weird look look smell I said
smell this is how they look like I think
it's pretty obvious which one is the
chili one I think we should spoon I
forgot the time it I don't know if
they're ready or not Oh God
now let's take them out this one doesn't
look bad you can't say that this is the
magic ones every cow sparkle Sparkle and
then we decorate here we have this guy
Liam where is where is Liam what the
[ __ ] where is this [ __ ] face taking a
closer look
okay well I'm gonna I'm gonna try one
that's gonna be great ah not bad yeah
hairy soul isn't it is okay I'll eat
I'll be Perry it's like ghost pepper
challenge wasn't bad enough now I have
to eat the higher a cupcake it's nothing
okay Harry
this one is for you don't want for my
breath
Oh
oh no Harry what did you do
Oh Oh Harry you are my best friend in
the whole world
Oh God Oh God oh I feel it I know make
it Fox bleep up I need to eat hmm
I mean oh my god oh my god oh my god
your [ __ ] codes are helping when does it
guys stop no wait that was the honey
cupcake
subscribe
brofist oh my god